hey we love making cheese I love eating
cheese
what do you mean making cheese Oh like
making cheese like cutting the cheese
you can eat it with savory things you
can eat it with see things can go wrong
with cheese so today we're gonna be
trying different cheese gadgets were
anything that will facilitate the
journey of cheese into my mouth is a
gadget that I'm on board with so yeah
her nose I'm excited let's see it's
called nose done here
grilled cheese is it like makes you feel
nostalgic that make you feel like your
kid and at home I just maybe I feel like
I'm in my kitchen eating cheese a
grilled cheese toaster I like this a lot
cuz this is fancy
you put the sandwich right there boom
boom boom boom put the cheese in the
middle Nessa Walla okay I learned
recently that all on toasters a lot of
times the numbers are minutes and not
degrees of toastiness I didn't know that
either so like three seems low but like
three minutes cheese I'm a no butter no
butter no ketchup Oh Jimmy you ketchup
don't you put ketchup on I'm good to you
there's a melt Demelza no more five six
there's a seven so I don't know what's
beyond the melt though you go preheat
and defrost you cheese that's crazy
I like a bit of cheese David she's laces
let's be generous that's coming out
let's go in the middle of the melts on
the side so this is only for grilled
cheese yeah what if I want to put
something else
Cheers feel like we're camping my cheese
is not melted it's a pretty golden color
though not super melted maybe we should
do it out of six I'll put one of my
slices back in gonna eat the other one
that you bit another cheese was not
melted so he just popped it back in I
like my cheese to be melted so if I go
like this you know maybe that was my
mistake
in doing two slices instead of one but
also like you know the breads pretty
think you want like a good cheese to
bread ratio look at that I don't see any
difference in the kind of like goat
cheese that will make in my house but
this is kind of crunchy if I know
someone that loves grilled cheese I feel
like this would be a really cute gift to
think I would rather have this than a
toaster alright so this is the fondue
l'heure
it's a hot glue gun but for cheese there
are many steps Marni cookies oh we
should check instructions ah okay come
on man we don't check instructions put
the paneer back in teeth side down which
way does it go in my patient for my
cheese name-o son that's too big oh my
pressed cheese tube into block Oh like
that I'll tell you how they say to do it
this is like a whole arts and crap
amazing six complete and if
plug in and wait until cheese melts
about three minutes don't weed crap this
is by the cheese fondue dealer could you
stop interrupting my ad perfect date
young but I'm ami got the crackers I got
the wine oh jeez go you've made my day
you're welcome oh but that one of those
cookies good oh of course
like a bad point the instructions say
lightly pull trigger until cheese
excuses supporting cheese juice live
they buggers that's not the best thing
to say that yeah oh this is working now
gosh I can't miss my leaf face my dreams
come true I thought it was gonna come
out like melted melted I'm not a fan I'd
much rather just go like this yeah does
it taste good does it taste better I
don't know it tastes better but it's an
interesting texture you can come out
like how you wanted to plow by to play
devil's advocate as well Oh have you
ever used the glue gun yeah no messy
yeah it's exactly what's promised to you
by the time it's successfully melted or
squirted cheese juice you're just like
I'm over it I think it's definitely
something like you'll give us a kid I
can give this to my god louder and she
will have a damn ball with this but are
you putting it on your girl yes I wanted
to pull the cheese if you eat it right
away it's good cheese is already fun
yeah Perry cheese doesn't need anything
else at it on Twitter
[Music]